шановні глядачі та глядачки
сподіваємося ви нас бачите та чуєте Я
прошу дати нам зворотний зв'язок в чаті
чи чуєте чи бачите ви нас чи не виникає
якихось
ів
Так дякую дуже за зворотний зв'язок бачу
що ви нас чуєте Бачите Мене звати
Олександр Папіш я експерт з онлайносвіти
І сьогодні ми раді вас вітати на нашому
навчальному заході на навчальному
вебінарі про електронну педагогіку
профтеху де Сьогодні ми вам розкажемо
про всі можливості щодо створення
власних курсів на онлайн-платформі
професійна освіта онлайн
Сьогодні у нас зустріч складається з
декількох частин і безпосередньо
передусім хочу надати слово пані Ірині
шумік генеральній директорці директорату
професійної освіти мон яка розповість
вам про діджіталізацію професійної
освіти в Україні і власне з якою метою
розроблялася безпосередньо платформа
професійна освіта онлайн пані Ірино вам
слово добрий день дякую Олександра
Добрий день шановні колеги щиро рада
вітати вас на сьогоднішньому вебінарі
сподіваємося як завжди ми зможемо вас
здивувати і зацікавити новими
можливостями які Ми створюємо для
дистанційної освіти і для кожного
педагога в напрямку оновлення
інструментів цифрового навчання а-а
дійсно трошки менше року тому назад
наприкінці грудня А ми презентували
платформу професійна освіта онлайн ця
платформа задумувалася ще в часи ковідні
а під час Великої війни стала взагалі
надзвичайно важливою тому що вона дає
можливість тим учням тим здобувачам
освіти які сьогодні знаходяться на
тимчасово окупованих територіях або
продовжують навчання дистанційно в
закладах але перебувають на інших
територіях долучитися і отримати якісний
зміст і можливість здобувати освіту
дійсно онлайн І за це величезнано подяка
нашим партнерам перш за все міжнародній
організації праці і Пані алесандрі мольц
яка сьогодні теж буде говорити
Сподіваюсь дуже-дуже скоро за те що вони
повірили в нас підтримали нашу ідею І
продовжують підтримувати далі за цей
період за декілька років поки ми
розробляли платформу запускали
розробляли курси до нас долучилися і
інші проекти і партнери зокрема які
фінансуються Європейським Союзом нашими
партнерським
країнами Німеччиною естонією фінляндією
Польщею і багато-багато інших навіть на
сьогодні є пропозиції від громадських
організацій щодо розміщення курсів і ми
можемо похвалитися на сьогодні на
платформі вже маємо понад 100 курсів і
ця кількість буде ще збільшуватися але
ми розуміємо
наскільки важливо для кожного
педагога особливо українського педаго га
мати певну свободу Свободу у викладанні
І дійсно дотримуватися оцієї
педагогічної автономії не просто на
папері а в реальності під час викладання
і саме тому було доопрацьовано цей один
з самих перших курсів розміщених на
платформі по електронній педагогіці який
був доопрацьований і на сьогодні
розповість про додаткові можливості
кожного викладача створювати власні
курси А головне можна буде цьому
навчитися додавати новий цікавий зміст
контент як ми звикли вже
говорити новими модними словами і
різноманітнити процес навчання Ми
сподіваємося що це з одного боку дасть
можливість самореалізувати
самореалізуватися викладачам і маємо
декілька наших методистів які вже
прийшли пілотно Цей курс і можуть дати
свої враження І свій зворотній зв'язок а
та ж власне дасть можливість отримати Ще
більше цікавих і корисних матеріалів
навчальних матеріалів у процесі здобуття
тої чи іншої професії або взагалі навіть
е у процесі здобуття чи набуття тих чи
інших е софт навичок м'яких навичок які
сьогодні надзвичайно важливих Я вас
вітаю до речі зараз із засідання
асоціації інсталяторів України і тут ми
обговорюємо як нам покращити підготовку
за професією Сантехнік тому активно
запрошую всіх хто ще не вміє або не
пробував користуватися нашою платформою
Я впевнена що ви знайдете для себе
багато чого цікавого АА заохочую
вчителів отримати нові знання Мені
здається що ця подорож в електронну
цифрову педагогіку буде для вас
надзвичайно цікавою і також надзвичайно
надзвичайно Дякую нашим партнерам
Олександри особисто і вам шановні колеги
Іван
Олександре Я знаю що у вас ще багато
колег за кадром за те що ваша команда
активно нас підтримує і допомагає са
саме вдосконалюватись
дякую пані Ірино дякуємо вам за
надихаюче мотиваційне слово передаю
слово і привітання пану Олексію ситнику
який є старшим проектним менеджером
проекту децентралізація управління та
цифровізація
ппто О привіт
друзі з багатьма з вас ми бачились та на
початку цього року ми з Іриною об'їздили
багато регіонів України і я вам
анонсував сьогоднішню подію що рано чи
пізно цей день настане І
власне сьогодні саме той момент коли цей
курс на Ну насправді курс вже працює і
вже там якщо мені пам'ять не зраджує 143
учасника навіть зареєстрована на ньому
але сьогодні ми презентуємо його вам і
коли колеги розкажуть власне як як ним
користуватись і чим він буде вам
корисний е з мого боку Ну ви знаєте Та у
нас е понад 300 професій які ми навчаємо
навчаємо там дітей а тепер вже зараз
робимо акценти на навчанні дорослих і
очевидно що це просто неймовірна
кількість освітніх матеріалів не може ні
одна компанія
там ні 10 компаній потягнути одночасно
таку кількість освітніх матеріалів
розробити і мені ну мені вкрай
важливо інтегрувати вас в цей процес як
безпосередніх з одного боку споживачів
освітнього контенту так то Які ті які
передають цей матеріал дітям своїм а з
іншого боку як творців і мені для мене
дуже важливо було дати
можливість створювати вам свій власний
освітній контент і дати дати можливість
зрештою ділитись зі своїми колегами щоб
ви могли поділити цю роботу та щоб ну
там хтось один один урок підготував
хтось інший інший і так далі тому я от
просто з нетерпінням чекаю цієї
презентації чекаю що ви включитесь в
подальшу роботу Ну і як ви знаєте як я
постійно наголошую ми зі свого боку
робитимемо все для того щоб вам було на
чому робити цей класний новий сучасний
контент
Дякую Дякуємо і передаю слово пані
Олександрі мольц яка є старшою
спеціалісткою з навичок та
працевлаштування міжнародної організації
праці пані Олександро вам
слово Так дякую вам
дуже добрий день Олексій Ірино Добрий
день колегам
з різноманітних до всіх тих вчителів які
сьогодні до нас доєдналися знаєте навіть
ця кількість 143 Це просто вражаюче Я
навіть не очікувала що ми відразу
отримаємо такий велике таке велике
охоплення знаєте насправді пройшло 11
місяців і один день з того моменту коли
ми вже запустили цю ідею почали
працювати над платформою і це настільки
приємно побачити як вона зараз
зростає і так ну якби останні раз я
брала участь тут в вебінарі разом з вами
А сьогодні ми запускаємо вже цей курс і
і це представлення цієї платформи Цей
курс для вчителів це все почалося в
принципі в один момент Це було в травні
2020 року коли ми просто обмінювались
ідеями коли в нас було Міністерство
освіти та науки України і наша
організація і коли ми сказали що ми
готові надати підтримку міністерства під
час ковіду під час пандемії і цей момент
оцієї цифровізації це коли ми надали
цифрову підтримку тому що в той момент
ми вже знали що після
пандемії ці переваги які ми зробили за
рахунок використання цифрових
інструментів
для для професійно-технічної освіти вони
залишаться тому що вони стануть частиною
цього сучасного підходу до навчання та
до вивче
контенту да для молодих людей до того
моменту коли пандемія була в розгарі це
це вже було те що нас здивувало але я
знаю скільки вчителів по всьому світі
наскільки вони страждали від того щоб
перейти від зустрічі з студентами з
учнями безпосередньо в навчальному класі
коли їм довелося перейти до використання
тих інструментів таких як зom Це ті
інструменти про які ми раніше навіть не
знали щоб почати з ними спілкуватися і
коли ти не маєш цього персоналізованого
особистого контакту коли ти все
здійснюєш через цифрові електронні
інструменти і це все дуже сильно змінило
в педагогіці в дидактиці яким чином ти
ставишся до своїх студентів до яким
чином Ти можеш оцінити своїх студентів
як ти можеш допомогти та підтримати
своїх студентів але також і як ти готуєш
середовище класів якій ти використовуєш
Отже в цьому травні 2020 року ми тоді
Сказали як щодо того щоб розробити курс
або якусь підтримку для тренерів для
вчителів щоб вони могли самі створювати
свій цифровий навчальний матеріал і це в
принципі мені здається що десь до січня
2021 року це був момент коли ми реально
почали працювати над проєктом
підготовкою цього курсу коли ми почали
шукати підтримуючі компанії проводити
співбесіди з вчителями з тренерами з
різноманітних науково-дослідних установ
навчальних установ і вже тоді в травні
21го року ми запустили першу пробну
версію від тої від того курсу який ми
зараз вже запускаємо повністю і мені
здається що Протягом цього періоду десь
45 вчителів та експертів педагогів
пройшли навчання і на той момент Це була
така змішаний формат вебінарів онлайн-
уроків самостійного навчання навчання за
власно власним темпом і також була
цифровий такий кампус на якому всі могли
пройти в практиці Де кожен учасник міг
створити свій власний матеріал і з цього
досвіду ми розробили дуже велику
кількість матеріалів навчальних
матеріалів для електри
для кухарів для для для проведення
ремонту автомобілів та
діагностики автомобілів і дуже велика
кількість людей які вже завершили той
перший курс
той і це відбулося
між вереснем 21го та груднем 2021 року і
ми тоді побачили Ну добре в нас є цей
курс Він дуже інтерактивний але я як ми
можемо вийти на більшу кількість
вчителів більшу кількість тренерів і як
ми ми от маємо цю дуже масивну важливу
роль з якої ми можемо вийти і перед тим
як Ми зрозуміли як ми можемо це
зробити інша
трагедія яка для нас ну прийшла таким
собі неприємним сюрпризом Це військова
агресія Росії проти України і в ті перші
дні я я насправді думала що все втрачено
що всі переваги які ми отримали що це
все
тарма І тільки на третій день після
повномасштабного
вторгнення я не тільки зрозуміла
наскільки стійкими є
українці Наскільки Ви націлені на захист
своєї країни але ще й наскільки стійким
є Міністерство освіти та науки України
наскільки всі міжнародні партнери були
стійкими та сказали що вони готові вчити
надалі вчити студентів вчити педагогів
що ми готові працювати над майбутнім
тому що для них має бути
майбутнє і так само ці всі люди це
будуть те майбутнє ті люди які будуть
проводити реконструкцію відновлення
України і Отже Ми почали знову обмін
ідеями і Міністерство нам сказало
Давайте ми оновимо цей курс Давайте ми
щось зробимо трошки інакше давайте Ми
змінимо контент давайте ми побачимо ті
уроки які ми змогли засвоїти Той досвід
і як ми можемо його використати і як ми
можемо вже його розмістити на платформі
профтехо освіти і тоді ми можемо сказати
і говорити до сотень сотень різних
вчителів та студентів і зараз мені дуже
приємно що тепер ця Ці вчителі можуть
навчатися цю новій версії цього курсу і
що ми можемо їм показати яким чином Цей
курс може функціонувати і тепер ми
можемо рухатися вперед і розвиватися і
ми можемо давати вам ще більше сили та
натхнення та підтримки і щоб ви могли ще
ще й більше надавати підтримку тим
молодим людям які пізніше
відновлюватимуть Україну Олексій сказав
що що ми всі Да
створювали і я хочу сказати всім вам тим
креейторам та тим хто створював ті щоб
ви вчилися щоб ви створювали свій
матеріал щоб ви могли ще більше виходити
не на на на більшу аудиторію щоб
надавати підтримку вчителям щоб вони
могли готувати молодих людей для
майбутнього я бажаю вам всім всього
самого найкращого Я сподіваюсь що це
буде великий успіх і я з нетерпінням
чекаю на те щоб почути ще більше більше
про результати такі мотиваційні слова і
насправді мета цього курсу і
сьогоднішнього заходу - це надихнути
допомогти всім слухачам і слухачкам
викладачам викладачкам е навчальних
закладів не тільки створювати свої
освітні матеріали Але в тому числі
вдосконалювати свої навички щодо
розробки там е створення онлайн-курсів і
в цьому вам в тому числі допоможе
онлайн-курс який було спеціально для вас
розроблений для фахівців і представників
представництв професійно-технічної
освіти цей онлайн-курс який є
акредитованим уюро він зможе і надасть
вам необхідні навички та безпосередньо
розуміння яким чином створити
безпосередньо сучасний онлайн-курс для
ваших студентів та студенток і до слова
запрошую Ірину короткову без яка власне
була фахівці фахівчиною зі створення
онлайн-курсу е і представляє компанію
ракунен
Ірино так Доброго дня Я сподіваюся що
мене добре чутно А що я можу сказати я
Буду намагатися бути коротшою своїх
висловлюваннях перше дякую всім що ви
долучилися до цього до цього вебінару до
цього процесу до того до процесу
створення курсів на
онлайн-платформі створення власних
курсів чи редагування курсів То вже буде
наступні кроки з вашої сторони
і До мене прийшли матеріали які ми
переробили під наш ринок так скажемо під
українських викладачів
і Якщо десь у курсі Ви зауважите що це
не співпадає з реальністю будь ласка
дайте нам знати Ми хочемо щоб цей курс
був гарним помічником для вас на першому
етапі перед тим як ви зможете створювати
свої курси
тому я бажаю вам успіху я далі вам
розповім про цей курс більш детально з
чого він складається Як ви можете його
проходити особливості цього курсу як
отримати сертифікат І нащо воно все вам
треба тобто головна ідея цього курсу А
Саша скажи мені будь ласка в мене тільки
вступне слово Чи я можу
продовжувати ні Ти можеш продовжувати
Добре тоді я пошарю вам екран а в чаті
вже всі чекають супер так дійсно Давайте
будемо по темі нашого Так перепрошую
що було відкрито все ох так є Тобто ми з
вами знаходимося на платформі я тут
скрию всіх е ми з вами знаходимося на
платформі всеукраїнська школа онлайн Тут
ви знайдете свій курс на нього можна
буде зареєструватися тобто у вас
по-перше повинен бути створений вже
акаунт на цій платформі А я тут під
своїм акаунтом ви створите свій власний
акаунт якщо у вас ще до цього цього його
не було Це буде легко дивіться я не знаю
рівень вашої
е володіння комп'ютером та рівень того
як ви вмієте користуватися онлайн
веб-ресурсами тому я орієнтована на
середнього користувача який знає як
створити свій акаунт але якщо ви не
знаєте як це зробити Я думаю що е
Олександр або хтось з підтримки
всеукраїнської школи онлайн профосвіти
зможуть Вам допомогти з цим тому будь
ласка питайте і ви зможете створити свій
акаунт А ви будете бачити курс у вас
буде тут кнопка яка позначається
зареєструватися Ви для мене це вже
продовжити курс а-а така іконка тут ви
зможете приї зможете побачити з чого
складається курс короткий опис але
давайте все ж таки подивимося з чого він
буде для вас
складатися є структура
вона невеличка є основні чотири модулі є
знайомство з платформою воно стоїть на
першому місці тому що вам треба розуміти
де які кнопки Це я знаю де кнопка
наступний тобто інструкція з проходження
курсу на платформі Я знаю де Який
наступний урок якими кнопками мені
користуватися що значать ці іконки що
значать ці позначки вперед назад і так
далі тому ми пропонуємо пройти спочатку
знайомство з платформою Тобто ви можете
викори то тут є картинки профіль тут все
є
неважко правда не важко просто треба
буде зосередитись трошки витратити часу
скільки часу середній час на проходження
курсу десь близько
а-а шести годин на тиждень Дайте мені
порахувати десь близько 25 годин це весь
курс Тобто ви проходите основну частину
теорію Це я вам проклацую навігацію на
платформі це все ще знайомство з
платформою
а далі у вас буде основна частина І у
вас буде
частина з вашим модульним проектом тобто
Ось так ми все проходимо І наприклад о
така іконка це значить що у вас тут є
тести Так у вас будуть тести це лише
приклад так як це розділ знайомство з
платформою якщо ми повернемося до
структури курсу далі У вас є запрошимо
до навчання є вступне опитування і
вступне опитування воно про ваші цілі
вкажіть ваше ім'я вашу електронну адресу
ваш вік є е-е обов'язкові поля А є
необов'язкові поля тому будь ласка
обов'язкові поля позначаються червоною
зірочкою необов'язкові поля нічого не не
не маєте бачите тут в кінці сеend
відправляєте І я побачу ваші відповіді і
потім ми вже подивимося на нашу
аудиторію і які в них цілі і чи
від ваших цілей Це допоможе також
покращити даний курс у майбутньому після
вступного опитування вас чекає А цілі та
завдання курсу ви зможете ї з ними
ознайомитись і е маленьке зауваження Цей
курс Як ви бачите вже побудований з за
методологію створення курсів коли ми
спочатку знайомимо людей з Давайте я
покажу трошки
себе ее коли ми спочатку знайомимо людей
з е платформою а потім бо якщо це для
вас невідома платформа вам потрібно
знати куди натискати е щоб проходити Цей
курс потім у вас обов'язково є вступна
частина де ви повинні прописати і ваші
цілі курсу з чого він складається
скільки це займає часу що потрібно мені
як учню Як цільові аудиторії слухачеві
Вибирайте для себе як ви будете називати
свою аудиторію А щоб скласти сти курс і
отримати сертифікат якщо він є тобто тут
на цій сторінці ви зможете знайти і
навчальні цілі і що ви будете знати
після завершення курсу і наперед кажу що
всі цілі Ми прописуємо з дієсловами
тобто що я можу робити Я можу щось
отримати щось набути І що це саме щось
знайти І що я буду мати у
кінці Я гадаю що ви це знаєте але як
маленьке нагадування умови отримання
сертифікату Обов'язково я повинен Як
учень знати учень учениця знати що мені
потрібно зробити щоб отримати сертифікат
або пройти до кінця і це треба писати на
початку курсу по тижням наприклад
це такий розклад Ви можете пройти за
один тиждень але це умовний розклад Як
ви можете проходити Як вам краще
проходити ці модулі вони повторюються ви
бачите модуль д модульт Тобто це наша
структура курсу і тижденьшість одна
година анкетування я ми до вас ми до
цього дойдемо як ви бачите тут є
курсовий проект на тижні чотири або
п'ять залежить від вас і у модулі чотири
ви познайомитесь з розробкою курсу на
платформі едекс як створювати свої
власні курси а в курсовому проекті вам
потрібно буде створити власний курс
чернетку тобто Цей курс буде тільки для
вас ви можете там
робити все що вам потрібно але також ви
можете
ее keep in
mind пам'ятати що цей курс який ви
будете створювати як чорнетку ви потім
можете використовувати далі для
створення курс реального на платформі
едекс і так Бажаємо вам успіхів і ми
переходимо до наступного пункту Де у вас
є обов'язково глосарій та абревіатура і
я вам дуже рекомендую використовувати
такі інструменти у своїх курсах
створювати пояснювальні е пояснення до
термінів до абревіатур бо інколи одні
одна абревіатура може мати різні
значення залежить від
а-а а від області в якій ми цю
абревіатуру використовуємо ви можете
завантажити його будь ласка
використовуйте вступне слово у вас є
інтерактивна презентація і давайте
трошечки інтерактивна презентація вона
розроблена таких побачити декілька у
курсів вона розроблена за програмою
articulate storyline Можливо ви чули
можливо ні може хтось у чаті прописати
будь ласка е назву цієї програми
articulate storyline Вона має Якщо ви
хочете для себе ее подивитися про цей
інструмент ми розкажемо в цьому курсі
також він має як безкоштовну підписку на
60 днів або вже платну підписку досить
суттєво по грошам на рік але це
на ваш розсуд і Тут в вас є кнопочка
Play І ви будете проглядати далі слайди
ви можете клікнути на ось цей
квадратик Він має озвучку коли озвучка
закінчується вона буде як відкриватися
так і давайте я трошки примотаю як
автоматично так і Потім ви зможете
самостійно ї використовувати А якщо вам
потрібно заново пройти і прочитати що
тут є і ви можете його в відкрити на
повний екран для більшої видимості Я не
знаю як вам хочеться ви можете ось
звучка
регулюється голос перепройти слайд і так
далі є також кнопка повноекранний режим
Вона працює точно так же як ось ці ось
цей квадратик і так ми переходимо далі
Тобто ви побачите вступне слово і далі у
вас не буде ніяких перешкод у вас є
передмодульне оцінювання що таке
передмодульне оцінювання на На даному у
курсі воно буде майже повторюватися на
фінальному оцінюванні тобто тут ви
проходите його і можете для себе
розуміти Окей чи я на на який бал Я здав
це оцінювання е Це мій рівень так
скажемо
е моя позиція локація
е перша так і в кінці курсу яка куди я
дойду Да так з точки А до точки б ее Чи
буде у вас кращий результат це навіть
більш для вашого
розуміння повертаємося до курсу до
структури у вас є модуль один він
складається з лекцій і є також
оцінювання шість завдань і є практичне
завдання Е
Там інтерактивне завдання ви побачите Я
сподіваюся що воно вам сподобається не
буду вам відкривати все зараз модуль два
ее ви бачите по назві що тут є і також є
обов'язкове оцінювання модуль
3 розкриваємо теми і модуль 4 модуль 4 -
це вже безпосередньо платформа на якій
ми з вами знаходимось на якій
розташований Цей курс опублікований і де
розташовані опубліковані курси для
профосвіти то тут ми з вами
вчимося як створювати і як взагалі
працювати конкретно з
едекс тобто весь цей модуль 4тири він
про платформу еedкс що там є як
створювати оцінювання як керувати курсом
розширені налаштування робота з
компонентами які що таке компоненти
давайте переглянемо Я дуже сподіваюся я
вас не злякаю бо там їх декілька Але у
вас є весь контент який у вас є для
вашого курсу ви створюєте тільки в
юнітах що таке юніти ви дізнаєтеся на
курсі але якщо бути спойлером то це ось
безпосередньо отакий компонент Де ми
зараз знаходимо оце називається юit А я
залишила назву unт і не прикладала її бо
ви будете її
бачити
у студії Так зараз підуть багато
невідомих можливо слів Давайте так все
що ви публікуєте і все що ви зараз
бачите і будуть бачити ваші слухачі це
називається lms так Learning management
System
або
система О а тут я зараз і
стала я як ми це українсько називаємо
Підкажіть мені будь
ласка чи є якесь загальна
назва система
управ Окей система управління освітою
навчальним процесом платформа Давайте
так навчальна платформа простими словами
так є щось тут у
чаті Окей добре Саша
е Давайте
так Окей Саша розкаже потім
Е тут ось це такі є компоненти Далі ви
побачите це можуть бути html-код
відеозавдання відповідь у вільній формі
щось додаткове обговорення про це все ви
дізнаєтеся безпосередньо Коли ви будете
проходити курс тому я не буду на цьому
дуже багато
зосереджуватися ми намагали описати і
далі є відео пояснення як це створювати
і так далі Не хвилюйтесь що тут різні
кольори Це єдине що їх відрізняє
Наприклад тут коричневий і Зелений колір
тут у нас зелений і синій тобто
функціонал працює так само А тут ви
проходите у модулі чотири ви пройдете
всі етапи як створювати курс і потім у
вас є модульний проект Нащо вам це все
треба і модульний проект в тому числі
слі Бо коли ви захочете створювати свої
курси на платформі профосвіта ви повинні
знати як вам додати картинку Як додати
відео як вам змінити щось Як
вам зробити нове можливе оцінювання на
курсі тобто цей модульчотири Спочатку ви
вчаєте все про те як загалом які
інструменти для створення
онлайн-контенту як Best найкращий ктики
створення онлайн створення навчальних
документів для онлайн навчання ви
дивитись про те які які є інструменти
які вам можуть допомогти у цьому а потім
вже безпосередньо як це робити на
платформі едекс з якою ви будете
працювати і модульний курсовий проект це
саме про
те
протренування безпосередньо щоб ви могли
тут якщо ви зможете наробити якихось
помилок на клікати на усі кнопки
подивитися як це працює і потім впевнено
йти на платформу профосвіти і вже
створювати свої курси або редагувати
курси які були створені іншими авторами
і курсовий проект Він має декілька тут
написано одне завдання але там
декілька тут описано що ви будете що вам
треба зробити обов'язкова інструкція де
Три кроки тобто перше вам треба буде е
під тувати деякі матеріали для вашого
умовного курсу далі безпосередньо
створити його на платформі і побачити і
поділитися з ним з вашими колегами і
двоє колег повинні будуть його
перевірити і тоді ви отримаєте
сертифікат а далі що не робити з цим
сертифікатами на що вам треба Я думаю що
Саша також да розповість основну ідею
ось завдання курсового проекту У вас є
воно не важке правда вам просто треба
буде виділити на це десь близько 10
годин так е Можливо ви зможете
виділити Давайте так експерти з якими я
працювала вони були викладачі і вони
після їх робочого дня працювали зі мною
над цим курсом тому вам треба буде
поговорити з вашою родиною щоб вони
виділили вам можливість дали вам цей час
гуляли з собаками з дітьми варили їсти
прибирали і все інше щоб ви могли
завершити Цей курс вдало отримати
сертифікат і далі робити свою роботу на
платформі
едекс тому в мене правда не важке але
якщо у вас є якщо у вас в процесі
створення курсу і цього модульного
проекту будуть питання будь ласка мені
не важко на них
відповідати Так дякую Олександр і будемо
дивитися як ми зможемо з вами зробити це
найкращим чином давайте один момент який
Я точно хочу проговорити ось тут Куди
Вам безпосередньо тобто коли ви створили
Ваш курс
ее це буде він майже буде виглядати так
само і в нього буде посилання тут мені
трошечки не видно ой в нього буде
посилання вам треба буде скопіювати ваше
посилання на ваш курс і надіслати його
от сюди зберегти свій прогрес і
натиснути сюди відповідь потім У вас іде
етап другий оцініть однокурсників Як
тільки ви відправите сюди свою відповідь
у вас тут з'явиться віконце з іншою
лінкою з іншим посиланням ваших
однокурсників на цьому курсі які вам
треба буде перевірити за критеріями які
ми вже Прописали для вас Тобто це не
повинно стати для вас проблемою але якщо
будуть питання будь ласка звертайтесь до
тих людей які допомагають вам у
проходженні цього курсу Ну і далі вже
буде ваша оцінка
безпосередньо і останнє що буде на цьому
курсі - це анкета задоволеності
навчанням та анкета щодо намірів
навчання вони невеличкі пройти буде
нескладно 4чотири-5ть Я думаю що ви
зможете це зробити Тим паче що в мене
вже є близько 50 анкет і які ми можемо
аналізувати і робити курси добрими
кращими за те що ми маємо вже зараз
Олександр
Окей
тут Що
ще що
ще я не знаю чи є у вас питання до мене
будь ласка я рада відповісти на них поки
я тут поки це в нас з вами живе
спілкування так Іро Дякуємо шановні
глядачі глядачки ставте будь ласка свої
запитання Я одразу відповім на ті які я
мав змогу побачити що щодо того чи курс
безкоштовний Так звісно курс
безкоштовний навчання є безкоштовним
навчання не містить ніяких термінів
дедлайнів ви можете проходити в гнучкому
для себе в форматі ее власне Якщо
говорити про мету навчання крім того
щоби здобути отримати оновити нові
навички та можливості щодо створення
онлайн-курсів А це навчання є
обов'язковим щоби ви могли
створювати власні онлайн-курси на
професій на платформі профтехо освіта
онлайн тобто без проходження цього курсу
вам не буде доступний функціонал для
редагування курсів та створення власних
тому Як тільки ви отримаєте сертифікат
про який Іра зауважувала вам відкриється
така можливість
а далі питання які ще тут безпосередньо
звучали щодо того де знайти курс курс
доступний на платформі профосвіта онлайн
і я окремо ще додатково вам його
продемонструю Як його знайти
а далі чи буде запис трансляції так за
цими посиланнями які ви бачили в анонсі
ви в будь-який час Зможете доєднатися і
повторно переглянути запис
трансляції так і Отже Іро наступні
питання які адресуються безпосередньо
тобі в чому різниця між Google
платформою Classroom і нашою платформою
на базі openedк О дуже гарне питання ну
дивіться я не можу сказати по-перше
Наскільки я знаю Е то ми використовує
Декс платформу бо це було Скажімо так
офіційне рішення
і за моєю думкою ува моєю особистою
думкою е Якщо вам з edк Google edк було
б працювати вам простіше і там все
відніше і там немає стільки багато
налаштувань які є тут але з Google
Classroom У вас є в основному з Google
Classroom ми працюємо з е
Ми ділимося документами ділимося лінками
щось відкривається є комунікація з
учнями може бути в коментарях але тут у
вас є такий блок як обговорення де Ви
також можете спілкуватися з вашими
слухачами
Е для мене еedкс більше можливості по
інтерактивним моментам і по інструментам
які ми можемо тут використовувати і по
контролю Google Classroom я не пам'ятай
щоб там можна було відслідковувати
оцінки з особливо з інтерактивних
продуктів таких як Давайте я не знаю чи
знайоми з цим словом з корми файлів ось
цього я не бачила в Google Classroom
можливо мені можливо ви мені скажете що
так це можливо е якщо потрібна більш
широка відповідь на це питання я можу
вам
підготувати порівняльною табличкою
відправити кому це потрібно і цим Ми
закриємо це але давайте Давайте так ви
проходите Цей курс для того щоб
навчитися працювати з едекс бо курси на
для профосвіти вони курси для навчання
АА безпосередньо з про Проф проф
профтехні технічних освіт так не про
освіт професій Вони знаходяться на едекс
і вам потрібно працювати з edкс тому ми
тут повертаємося до еedкс і як тут як
тут це робити Ви можете використовувати
Google Classroom Я вважаю для своїх
власних потреб якщо щось не вистачає вам
у едекс так Дякуємо Іро якщо підсумувати
то поточна платформа дає вам більше
можливостей і вона є значно гнучкішою
для створення власних онлайн-курсів з
інтерактивними елементами тому і було
вирішено використовувати цей
безпосередньо функціонал для того щоб ви
могли створювати власні онлайн-курси а
далі швидко рухаюся по питанням і будемо
переходити до наступної частини
презентації безпосередньо як створювати
курси скільки часу відділено для
розробки власного курсу чи є обмеження
дивіться обмежень по створенню власних
курсів немає Якщо ж ви зауважуєте про
курсову роботу Так з точки зору того аби
отримати е-е сертифікат після
проходження курсу ТО Майте на увазі що
курс який вам треба буде створити в
межах курсової роботи а він розміщений е
на тестовій платформі про яку сьогодні
Ірина згадувала І там після того як ви
створите курс Він є в доступі впродовж
трьох наступних місяців ще раз це мова
про тестову платформу яка тільки для
того щоби ви могли потренуватися і здати
курсову роботу якщо ж ми говоримо про
можливість створювати курси на платформі
профосвіта то ви маєте необмежений час
для їхнього створення вони будуть
доступні повсяк час і немає жодних
якихось дедлайнів а далі запитання е чи
можна змінити свою роль на платформі
наприклад з слухача-слухачки на
учитель-учителька Так ви можете
звернутися в службу підтримки які дані
які є вказані
в на платформі на сам кінець сторінки і
а технічна підтримка вам зможе допомогти
з вирішенням цього питання А в якому
вигляді буде сертифікат по закінченню
курсу Я вам зараз його продемонструю
власне де його шукати і детально на
цьому зупинюся АА який максимальний
об'єм сховищі щодо створення курсів Вам
не потрібно заце хвилюватися Ви маєте
можливість розробляти курс відповідно до
тих до тої структури тої кількості
матеріалів яка вам є необхідною
а далі ее слідкую за питанням
м чи курси потрібно створювати лише з
предметів професійного спрямування чи
можна із загальноосвітніх предметів а
власне безпосередньо можливість
створювати власні онлайн-курси доступно
на платформі професвіта онлайн як власні
так і на підставі вже наявних курсів Я
теж про цей функціонал зараз розкажу
тому ви можете створювати різного
формату курси і різного спрямування
тематичного а щодо посилань ви зараз все
зможете ще раз повторно побачити чи
можна чи має працювати увесь навчальний
заклад на цій платформі ви вирішуєте це
в межах вашого навчального закладу Як
вам комфортно А чи буде курс у записі
Так звісно і трансляція і курс доступні
до перегляду до навчання по всякчас за
посиланнями в анонсі А чи буде в
майбутньому можливість перенести курс
тестової платформи на платформу
профосвіти А на жаль наразі
імпорт-експорт
не доступний тому власне знову ж таки
після того як ви віднавчалися на
тестовій платформі ви вже Можете
розпочати повноцінну реалізацію власних
курсів на безпосередньо платформі на для
створення курсів на профосвіті онлайн а
якщо вже є курс на професійна освіта
онлайн і бажання створення ще одного чи
потрібно все одно Пройти навчання та
отримати сертифікат ні Дивіться ви
проходите навчання на курсі професійна
освіта онлайн і отримуєте сертифікат на
платформі профсю Я зараз це ще раз
продемонструю
а отже Да і далі вже всі були питання
щодо того де шукати цей курс Отже я са
са Саш пробачи пере переб спитали чи є
якщо вже створили якщо я так поняла що
людина вже створила свій курс чи їй
потрібно заново проходити навчання якщо
вона вміє працювати в едексі і
створювати курс вам все одно доведеться
Пройти навчання на курсі тому що
наявність і отримання сертифікату є
безпосередньо Обов'язковою умовою щоб
вам відкрився технічний доступ до
платформи з можливістю редагувати та
створювати власні онлайн-курси якщо
сертифікату немає у вашому акаунті
відповідно Ви не зможете
цей функціонал не буде у вас працювати
Тому це є обов'язковою вимогою для цієї
людини модульний проект просто буде
займати умовно не 10 годин Він повинен
прочитати роздивитися розглянути і
наприклад модуль 4 він може ознайомитись
і Можливо ви щось новеньке для себе під
підкреслите у цьому модулі якщо ви вже
знаєте як працювати дек і модульний
проект ви зможете зробити не за 10 годин
наприклад А за дві тобто для вас цей
курс буде швидшей в проходженні модуля
4отири та модульного кот льного
курсового проекту А ось тут де
фасилітація та електронна педагогіка
навчальні технології можливо не можливо
а я сподіваюся що тут ви для себе
підчерпнете якусь нову інформацію яку
зможете використовувати в своєму новому
курсі так Дякую Іро і я власне продовжу
далі презентацію ми переходимо вже до
безпосередньої секції Можна я Вибачте
будь ласка перед презентацією так що щоб
не перебивати в мене два коротких дві
коротких відповіді як у адміністратора
Так значить перше було запитання Чи
обов'язково закладу переходити на едекс
Чи обов'язково всьому закладу
використовувати едекс розглядай
розглядайте будь ласка Якщо у вас є там
свій не знаю там той же Google Classroom
чи ще що-небудь розглядайте будь ласка
професійну освіту онлайн як репозитарій
як сховище навчальних матеріалів Так там
є системи оцінювання так є сертифікати
але в першу чергу ми працюємо над тим
щоби наповнити це корисним для вас
контентом щоб ви це могли
використовувати ці матеріали під час
своїх уроків відповідно щоб учні Там Чи
ті хто бажають підвищити кваліфікацію
могли проходити ці уроки тобто в ну для
мене в першу чергу це репозитарій
освітніх матеріалів
е перш перша відповідь і друга чи можна
з пісочниці та або з тестової платформи
перенести курс на основну платформу Якщо
раптом ваш курсовий проект буде такий
класний що вам його захочеться перенести
на основну платформу Напишіть нам в
техпідтримку і ми зробимо Це руками да
функції експорту імпорту немає але в
мене є спеціально навчена людина для
цього от тому на Ну я тільки за те щоби
хороший і якісний контент
з'являвся на платформі Дякую
Олександре Так дякую вам за додаткові
уточнення Отже слухачі та слухачки Я
переходжу до фінальної частини нашої
зустрічі ми трошки перебрали по таймінгу
тому завершимо буквально на 10 хвилин
пізніше нашу зустріч але я сподіваюся що
вам буде дуже цікаво і корисно і зараз
ви зможете побачити безпосередньо
практичну площину того як створювати
власні онлайн-курси на професійній
освіті онлайн А зараз я розпочну
демонстрацію свого екрану перед тим я
прошу і Зак закликаю вас ставити свої
питання в чатах Я слідкую за обидвома
чатами і зможу оперативно відповісти на
ваші запитання та уточнення так от зараз
ви
бачите безпосередньо всім нам знайому
платформу професійна освіта онлайн вона
доступна за за безпосередньо посиланням
проosвіita.online повсякчас 24х7 Ще раз
зауважу Хто ще не знає що платформа є
абсолютно безкоштовною функціонал який
ми сьогодні вам презентуємо теж є
безкоштовним курс про який ми говорили
теж безкоштовний тобто вам надали всі
можливі інструменти для того щоб ви
створювали власні онлайн-курси для ваших
студентів та студенток в будь-якому
часовому проміжку або незалежно від того
де ви знаходитеся як знайти курс це
певно було найбільш популярним
запитанням сьогоднішньої зустрічі знову
ж таки курс доступний на платформі
професійна освіта онлайн є два способи
щоб його знайти перше ший найлегший
спосіб ви можете ввести словосполучення
електронна педагогіка одну
[музика]
хвилинку і ось одразу ось в топі нашого
пошуковику є ось цей курс який сьогодні
ми вам демонстрували і якщо ви натиснете
на дізнатися більше ви зможете побачити
безпосередньо всі ключові деталі щодо
цього курсу його інформацію про
структуру і безпосередньо можливість
зареєструватися на курс так а-а для
цього треба увійти в кабінет свій зараз
я вам це теж продемонструю другий спосіб
як знайти цей курс безпосередньо в в цих
категоріях які наразі тут доступні можна
знайти вкладку для педагогів та
керівників закладів ппто а натиснувши
детальніше ви зможете одразу ось тут
знайти курс тобто є два шляхи для того
щоби розпочати навчання на курсі як я
вже сказав щоби розпочати навчання
необхідно спершу зареєструватися на
платформі якщо ви цього ще не зробили
або ж авторизуватися якщо ви вже
безпосередньо зареєстровані тобто є
можливість як зареєструватися на
платформі реєстрація займає буквально до
декількох хвилин не більше Однак я хочу
звернути вашу увагу а що Як тільки ви
заре створити свій обліковий запис щоби
ви фактично зареєструвалися вам
необхідно отримати на електронну пошту
листа пересвідчитися що ви його отримали
і активувати обліковий запис тобто вам
прийде лист на електронну пошту з
активацією вашого облікового запису
Пам'ятайте про цей важливий момент тому
що якщо ви не активуєте свій обліковий
запис вам не буде доступний взагалі
середовище щодо створення або копіювання
наявних курсів на платформі Тому це дуже
важливий момент Як тільки ви
зареєструвалися лист вам не надійшов
спершу перевірте папку спам або реклама
у вашому вашій електронній пошті лист
надходить буквально впродовж декількох
секунд після реєстрації а далі якщо якщо
ви вже маєте створений акаунт вам
достатньо увійти власне те що я зараз і
зроблю я вже підготував свій обліковий е
обліковий запис для того щоби в нього
безпосередньо увійти і Як бачите я вже
записаний на цей курс тому в мене і
статус інакший у вас тут з'явиться
кнопка зареєструватися на курс Як тільки
ви зареєструєтеся ви одразу потрапите в
середовище цього курсу яке сьогодні вам
демонструвала і
і якщо ми вже говорили про цей аспект що
саме в модулі чотири детально покроково
все те що я вам зараз буду розповідати
Ви також зможете знайти в текстовому
форматі А якщо ми говоримо про ключові
речі які є важливими пам'ятаючи щодо
створення своїх власних онлайн-курсів То
ми сьогодні на ефірі про це дуже багато
говорили що для того щоби вам став
доступним функціонал вам треба пройти
успішно Цей
курс власне засвідченням того що ви
пройшли успішно Цей курс є ваш
сертифікат як знайти ваш сертифікат
власне коли ви на в правому верхньому
куточку клікнете на ваші на ваш нікнейм
вам стане доступним вкладка мої курси
або у верхній панелі меню ви зможете
натиснути на мої курси і ось тут буде
вкладка курси від вшо і У ній є
безпосередньо курс на який ви
зареєструвалися на нашій платформі в наш
му випадку це курс про те як створювати
модульний контент електронна педагогіка
і Як бачите я вже пройшов Цей курс я
отримав сертифікат І власне отут і є
можливість завантажити переглянути
сертифікат тобто Як тільки ви здасте
свою курсову роботу і її буде перевірено
саме перевірено іншими слухачами
слухачками курсу а відповідно до вашої
успішності на курсі вам буде видано
сертифікат власне пересвідчитися що
ви його його отримали можете у вкладці
мої курси ось має бути така кнопка
переглянути сертифікат це означає що у
вас весь функціонал який я буду зараз
демонструвати працюватиме безперешкодно
без зайвих якихось турбот і ви зможете
створити свій курс буквально в декілька
кліків що ми зараз і будемо з вами
робити так от які власне кроки для того
щоби створити свій курс на платформі
професійно освіта онлайн Крок перший
натискаємо на вкладку мій кабінет вона
доступна у Верхньому панелі меню але
дорогі слухачі та слухачки ще раз
зауважую що якщо ви свій обліковий запис
не активуєте після реєстрації ця вкладка
не буде вам доступна тому я двічі вже
третій раз наголошую що обов'язково
активуйте свій обліковий запис через
вашу електронну пошту після реєстрації
так от а-а Мій кабінет натискаємо і е
знову ж таки як тільки ви е натиснете на
цю кнопку вам ось буде доступним ось це
меню спершу вам треба буде опрацювати
інструкційні
матеріали будь ласка поставтеся До цього
дуже відповідально тому що безпосередньо
всі ці інструкційні матеріали покажуть
вам як працювати з середовищем Мій
кабінет цей середовище Мій кабінет
дозволить вам в тому числі скопіювати
поточні курси які є на платформі
профосвіта онлайн а потім їх Реда вати
тобто будь-який ось цей курс я от зараз
їх продемонструю повторно ось цей
будь-який курс із цього переліку з цих
категорії А ви ви зможете
скопіювати і на основі цього курсу
створити свій власний курс тобто
доповнити запросити на нього ваших
студентів-студенток Тобто ми вам вже
даємо основу базу яку ви зможете
розширювати доповнювати як завгодно
головне щоби у вас було бажання це
робити І звісно використовувати різні
методичні та інтерактивні підходи так
ось ця інструкційні всі матеріали ці всі
інструкційні матеріали допоможуть вам
розібратися покроково як працювати з
платформою що таке кабінет вчителя це от
власне кабінет який ми тут в якому
працюємо а і багато-багато іншого Як
тільки ви опрацюєте всі матеріали а
обов'язково відмічаємо що ми опрацювали
ці матеріали і натискаємо на кнопку
розпочати А вам одразу стане доступною
друга вкладка вони будуть відкриватися
по черзі тобто спершу інструкція
наступна вкладка як ви тільки натиснете
на кнопку розпочати це вкладка запросити
учнів та учениць на курс і ось власне
це наступний крок третій вже по нашой
калькуляції крок для того щоби створити
свій власний курс на основі курсу
платформи про професійна освіта онлайн А
що ми спершу робимо а в нас в нас є дві
категорії Тобто ми можемо скопіювати
курс або ж з профосвіти онлайн Це ті
курси які я вам щойно демонстрував
буквально декілька хвилин тому і у нас є
Курси курси vшо - це відома всім певно
платформа всеукраїнська школа онлайн
залежно від того чого ви навчаєте ваших
студентів та студенток в нашому випадку
ми розглядаємо платформу профосвіта тому
обираючи певну професію кваліфікацію
наприклад візьмемо візашист А вам
далі буде відкрита можливість обрати
відповідний курс до цієї категорії у
нашому випадку по категорії візажист
наразі є тільки курс основи підготовки
обличчя до макіяжу обрали його
натискаємо на кнопку готово Як ви бачите
з'являється інформаційне повідомлення що
розпочався процес копіювання курсу і
після успішного завершення процесу ви
зможете побачити Ваш курс у вкладці
управління курсами де шукати цю вкладку
ви Спитаєте А ось вона вона одразу ось
тут але ви Ви маєте також очі мати собі
на увазі що А Власне цей процес займає
певний час власне компіляція курсу тому
не хвилюйтеся якщо він одразу у вас не
з'явився це займе буквально одну-дві
хвилини і далі у вас курс буде доступний
у вкладці управління курсами Як бачите
він у мене ще недоступний тому що ще
триває процес компіляції але через
декілька хвилин він з'явиться з огляду
на те що в нас Ми обмежені по часу в
трансляції Я одразу покажу приклад
роботи з курсом на тих курсах на яких
вже я зареєстрований але ви зможете
відповідно вже безпосередньо ваші курси
Таким чином також редагувати але
Зверніть увагу що у вкладці управління
курсами не тільки
з'явиться той курс який ви скомпілювали
да скопіювали з платформи профосвіта
онлайн але і можливість створити власний
курс новий курс Тобто ми вам даємо дві
можливості перше - це працювати з осново
ю базою тих курсів які ми вже розробили
з професійними експертами методистами
викладачами і ви можете на основі них
створювати власні доопрацьовувати їх і
таким чином робити навчання захоплюючим
і цікавим для ваших студентів-студенток
або ж створити взагалі новий курс за
власною методологією за власною
програмою за будь-якими компонентами які
ви вважаєте за потрібне тут радше як я
вже сказав на початку залежить від ваших
цілей бажань і можливостей ми розглянемо
швидко два варіанти щоб вам було
зрозуміло як далі працювати рухаємося за
цим принципом що ми редагуємо той курс
який ви вже скопіювали ну наприклад я
візьму курс
а Історія України п'ятий клас А є дві
опції Як ви можете побачити редагувати І
запросити учнів та учениць припустимо Ви
не хочете змінювати Цей курс і вам
тільки хочеться на нього запросити ваших
студентів-студенток і для того щоб від
відстежувати їхній навчальний процес
їхній прогрес їхню активність на курсі
ви натискаєте на кнопку запросити учнів
та учениць і ви потрапите безпосередньо
в адміністративну панель Ось цього
конкретного курсу Бачите ми одразу в неї
потрапили вона називається панель
управління і тут є увесь необхідний
функціонал щоб ви запросили
безпосередньо ваших студентів-студенток
на курс організували наприклад класи
якщо це потрібно це власне можливість
розділити студентів на групи і далі
безпосеред безпосередньо слідкувати за
їхнім прогресом та успішністю Якщо ж ви
хочете спершу здійснити певні зміни в
курсі то вам треба натиснути на кнопку
редагувати і Дивіться що зараз станеться
коли ми натиснемо на кнопку редагувати
перш за все якщо у вас ви не пройдете
курс ось цей обов'язковий про який ми
казали Якщо ви клікнете на кнопку
редагувати вам з'явиться інформаційне
повідомлення Що ви не пройшли курс і не
можете редагувати Тобто
скомпілювати ви зможете запросити учнів
ви зможете але змінювати Ви не зможете
до того часу допоки не отримаєте
сертифікат Тому цей функціонал лише стає
доступним тоді коли ви отримаєте
сертифікат тепер є два це важливо про
термінологію ось це середовище в якому
ми зараз працюємо це навчальна платформа
за певною абревіатурою технічною вона
називається lms це скорочення від
Learning management System Коли ми
натискаємо на кнопку редагувати ми
потрапимо з вами в адміністративне
середовище да Тобто це адміністративна
платформа вона називається абревіатурою
CMS content management System або ж в
нас є така скорочена її назва яку Ви
зустрінете в курсі навчальному студія і
ось вона дозволяє так спрощено зрозуміти
що у вас є навча чальна платформа А є
студія ось безпосередньо в студії ви
якраз і зможете редагувати та створювати
власні курси поїхали наступний крок
редагувати а для того щоб почати процес
редагування Вам доведеться повторно
авторизуватися ми знову вводимо свої
дані які ми вказували вже перед цим на
платформі а натискаємо увійти і ось ми
потрапили з вами в те середовище яке
називається студія або cмs або
адміністративна частина платформи А ми
одразу потрапили з вами в той курс який
ми хочемо редагувати ви можете побачити
його назву історія України е-е і далі на
що необхідно звернути вашу увагу коли ви
потрапляєте в будь-яке ось таке нове
середовище може спершу здатися що це все
дуже складно дуже багато категорій
інформації тому власне і передбачений
процес навчання щоб ви спершу
ознайомилися з цим середовищем на
тестовій платформі формі а потім з усіма
вже навичками і можливостями змогли це
опрацювати в практичній площині на
безпосередньо платформі профосвіти
онлайн і робіть все Поступово не не
потрібно намагатися опанувати все за
один раз рухайтеся крок за кроком і як
ви бачите тут у нас дуже багато підказок
майже на кожному кроці У вас є певні
підказки наприклад ви можете зараз
побачити у правої панелі екрану що є
рекомендації про те як створювати
організацію курсу реорганізацію курсу а
встановлювати таймлайни вашого курсу да
тобто коли він з якого по число по яке
діє це допоміжні вам інструкції да на
вашому безпосередньо робочому кроці дуже
коротко по робочому інструментарію перше
у вас є уверху е адміністративне меню у
якому ви маєте наразі три категорії
називається ее перш за все це ось
контент тут є вкладки які ви зараз
бачите на екрані ми зараз коротко по
кожній пройдемося потім наступна
категорія налаштування і знову ж таки з
нікнеймом це радше можливість покинути
студію і а власне завершити Процес
розробки курсу А що таке вкладка контент
дуже коротко по ній пройдемося перша
категорія - структура курсу ось це
власне перша сторінка на яку ми
потрапили тут ви створюєте крок за
кроком ва шу структуру курсу Тобто Це
ваш Навчальний план це ркулум Тобто
outline можна називати по-різному це
фактично теми які є у вашій навчальній
програмі І власне на основі цієї
структури яку ви побудували завчасно ви
далі крок за кроком її наповнюєте ми це
теж швиденько сьогодні розглянемо а
наступна категорія оновлення що таке
оновлення
фактично якщо ви робите якісь оголошення
для для ваших студентів і студенток на
курсі ви їх публікуєте через
адміністративне середовище ось в цій
категорії яка називається оновлення
курсу ви Спитаєте А як це буде виглядати
безпосередньо на платформі давайте ж з
вами швидко глянемо ось якщо ми зайдемо
в вкладку мої курси Вибачте я мушу
швиденько ще раз зареєструватися увійти
точніше а
ось зараз ось курс історія України
п'ятий клас І як ви бачите ось курс який
ми скопіювали скопійований курс основи
підготовки обличчя до макіяжу він вже
доступний Тобто це зайняло буквально
декілька хвилин так от переходимо в курс
історія України ось ви можете побачити
що це оголошення курсу Яке Ось ви тут
бачите зараз Ось як воно відображається
безпосередньо на е платформі бачите
наразі доступна частина навчальних
матеріалів ось воно так відображається і
так кожне оголошення актуальне буде
відображатися в горі навчальної
навчальної платформи курсу а наступна
категорія у нас це сторінки що ти знову
Перепрошую
бачите система настільки захищена що
потребує кожного разу пере входження АА
далі наступна категорія - це сторінки
сторінки - це власне навчальні категорії
які відображаються ось тут на головній
панелі курсу е ось в форматі
горизонтального меню є прогрес дати
програма прооцінювання обговорення
управління курсом ось фактично Ось вони
тут розміщені є певні технічні які ви не
можете редагувати додавати А але інші
сторінки ви можете додавати і вони
будуть з'являтися Ось на цій панелі
уверху ви можете їх залежно від вашої
структури курсу додавати в такому
порядку і в такому форматі який вам
необхідний Далі є файли завантаження цю
сторінку ми використовуємо коли треба
додати якісь матеріали в курс А і Є
безпосередньо підручники якщо тут додати
свій власний якийсь е-е
гайдлайн або ж інструкцію у вигляді
підручника то вона стане доступною ось в
правовому куточку навчальної платформи а
налаштування е знову ж таки є можливість
працювати з вкладкою розклад і деталі
тут ви зможете налаштувати коли Ваш курс
починається завершується короткий опис
курсу
деталів про Ваш курс і так далі Це
допоможе вашим студентам побачити
візуальну загальну зведену інформацію
про курс плюс ви зможете звідси
скопіювати посилання на ваш курс да Яке
ви зможете далі наприклад або десь
опублікувати надіслати вашим студентам
якщо ви захочете це зробити через
посилання наступна категорія В
налаштуванні - це оцінювання тут ви
будете фіксувати і визначати ваші
навчальні категорії відповідно до
системи оцінювання яку ви придумаєте до
вашого курсу е безпосередньо наступна
вкладка команда курсу якщо ви працюєте
колаборуєте з вашими викладачами
колегами коліжанками ви можете їх сюди
додати і вони також отримають доступ до
вашого курсу а налаштування груп це от
Якраз те-класи це про ті класи про які
ми говорили їх тут теж можна
адмініструвати і є вкладка розширення
налаштування яка містить певні в тому
числі технічні особливості у ці клаці
вам треба спершу дуже уважно
ознайомитися з кожними категоріями щоб
правильно їх налаштувати і в цьому теж
допоможе навчання на курсі і остання
вкладка - це сертифікати тут наразі в
цьому курсі вимкнуто можливість режиму
сертифікати але його можна окремо
налаштувати знову ж таки ви це
переглянете на навчання тепер дуже
коротко спробуємо додати якийсь певний
контент в нашому курсі Як ви бачите це
робиться на сторінці структура курсу так
як ми скопіювали курс да То в нас уже
доступна певна структура з того курсу
який ми скопіювали давайте щоби можливо
це було більш наочніше я швиденько в
моєму кабінеті
а створю дуже швидко новий якийсь курс
от одразу зараз і ви побачите що це
робиться буквально в декілька кроків
натискаємо створити новий курс
потрапляємо майже в платформу зараз
знову треба авторизуватися знову ж таки
це все зроблено для е декількох етапів
захисту знову ж таки от ми натиснули
створити курс одразу потрапили в розділ
створити новий курс надаємо йому якусь
назву наприклад е
педагогіка далі організація там певний
навчальний заклад вказуєте свою назву
навчального закладу номер курсу це може
бути
е безпосередньо
а в Так перепрошую там де організація Ви
маєте
вказати на назву латиницею а наприклад я
введу слово School
а далі в номер курсу ви вводити будь-яку
нумерацію вашого курсу по вашому е плану
і запуск курсу - це приблизно період
часу коли ви плануєте запустити Ваш курс
натискаємо створити і ось вуаля ми
створили ваш перший курс буквально це
зайняло навіть менше хвилини часу далі
ми фактично наповнюємо Цей курс згідно
тої програми яка у вас існує тобто Ми
створюємо розділи наприклад У нас є
перший розділ це вступ ось ми його
одразу створили Як ви бачите платформа є
інтерактивною тобто натискаючи на певні
кнопки одразу з'являється можливість
додати їхні назви тобто тут Насправді
все працює інтуїтивно і сприяє тому що
вам Не доведеться дуже сильно
розбиратися якщо ви вже пройдете
навчання на курсі створили ми першу
перший таку безпосередньо розділ
категорію вступ далі В нас є є
підрозділи це фактично наступні уроки
які мають бути у розділі вступ
натискаємо новий підрозділ і відповідно
будемо його іменувати таким чином Як
е-е в нас воно побудовано по програмі Я
перепрошую в мене тут трохи проблема з
інтернетом зараз я перезавантажу
сторінку щоби продемонструвати як далі
ми рухаємося але фактично ось ці уроки
можна побачити на прикладі цього курсу А
це фактично от
такі окремішні категорії Ось бачите він
вже створився я назву його там урок один
і вже залежно від того як у вас
побудований навчальний план А створивши
ось ці уроки Давайте я прийду в такий
вже більш прикладний ви можете їх
наповнювати теж по певним секціям і ее
далі кожну вашу секцію уроку
наповнювати тим словом яке сказала Іра
юніти юніти - це фактично певні
компоненти які які є у вашому уроці вони
можуть бути як навчальні відео як
завдання як додаткові матеріали ви їх
всі додаєте через спеціальне меню яке
доступне внизу і воно поділено теж на
певні секції і ви фактично Ваш курс
збираєте як пазл додаєте обговорення
додаєте якісь додаткові інструменти
завдання відео а кожна така категорія
якщо обрати її наприклад я натисну відео
бачите є певний шаблон і ви фактично
можете редагувати цей шаблон змінювати
посилання відео а назву додати тут можна
субтитри також додати Тобто ви маєте
повноцінний функціонал для того щоби
створювати будь-який контент в тому
числі запитання їх теж можна редагувати
є
чудова панель яка допомагає їх зручно
комфортно створювати а наприклад
потрібно завдання множинного вибору ми
його обираємо а дивіться все що ви зараз
побачили ви зможете ще повторно детально
ретельно опрацювати на курсі і ось
зокрема і для цього існує курс який вам
допоможе безпосередньо в цьому і коли ви
створите свій власний курс
а-а з першого модулю з другого модулю в
такому форматі щоби на ньому могли
працювати ваші студенти і студентки ви
зможете побачити що а-е це робиться дуже
оперативно швидко радше Це залежить від
того як ви підійдете з точки зору
методології створення того чи іншого
курсу А якщо у вас виникають будь-які
запитання або виникають якісь проблеми
уточнення ви завжди можете звернутися до
технічної підтримки ось ви бачите внизу
на платформі профосвіта онлай контакти і
ви адресуючи свій запит надайте якомога
більше деталей правильно сформулюйте
тему вашого запиту і служба підтримки
зможе вам допомогти якщо у вас виникають
якісь певні проблеми та уточнення Але як
я вже сказав запорукою вашого успіху
буде успішне проходження ось курсу який
було спеціально для вас створений він
вам розкриє всі деталі як крок за кроком
ще раз створити будь-який курс на
платформі профосвіта онлайн А ми з вами
дуже оглядово пройшлися по цим ключовим
категоріям І зараз я швидко пройдуся по
ваших питаннях в чаті
А я постараюся швидко
знайти питання для того щоби вам
повідповідати зараз починаю з Ютуба
дивлюсь
дивлюся так це ми демонстрували
і Отже перше питання чи редагований курс
буде доступний для всіх на платформі він
доступним тільки буде для тих кого ви
запросите у ваш курс пам'ятаєте я
демонстрував вам вкладку запросити учнів
Та учениць ось тільки тих слухачів Та
слухачок яких ви запросите до себе на
курс тільки їм і буде доступний Ваш курс
тобто публічно на платформі він не
відображається а далі бачу наступне
запитання
АА наступне запитання учням потрібно теж
реєструватися якщо вас запросили ваші
викладачі то в такому випадку ви зможете
проходити навчання на платформі
АА я зареєстрована на платформі пройшла
курс у мене немає вкладки Мій кабінет а
пані Ірино
я спершу Перевірте чи ви заре валися
саме на платформі профосвіта онлайн А
по-друге чи ви активували свій обліковий
запис якщо все одно не вдається Напишіть
будь ласка на технічну підтримку вам в
цьому випадку
допоможуть Доброго дня Чи курси
робітничих професій на цій платформі є
так Звісно вони є і в дуже значній
кількості на різні напрямки і
професійного спрямування навчайтеся всі
курси безкоштовні О дякую Пані Олено ви
написали Дякую зробила все за кроком як
ви казали все вийшло бачите все працює і
для цього потрібно тільки декілька
кроків і бажання Тобто ми всі
інструменти вам надали
а більше запитань не бачу в Ютубі і
швидко зараз щеє ще одне скільки можна
зробити підрозділів дивіться немає
ніяких ограничений лімітів обмежень по
створенню кількості розділів ви можете
створювати стільки скільки Вам
потрібно так далі бачу питання у
Фейсбуці після редагування курсу він
зміниться і буде збережений для всіх
майбутніх користувачів пані Тетяно
відповідаю на ваше запитання що цей курс
який ви створите він відображається
тільки у вас і в тих слухачокслухачок
яких ви запросите він Тобто ви ніяк не
повпливаєте на оригінальний курс це
компіляція тому можете не хвилюватися і
працювати в межах вашого курсу з вашими
слухачами та слухачками
дивлюся ее далі ее Перепрошую дивлюсь
далі коментарі тому що коментарів дуже
багато і хочу відповісти на якомога
більшу кількість ваших коментарів так у
Фейсбуці е коментарів надче немає чи
можна створювати один курс декільком
авторам А так як ви бачили Ось тут в
вкладці налаштування є вкладка команда
курсу і ви можете запросити сюди ваших
колег коліжанок і таким чином Вони теж
будуть мати ось Цей курс у себе в
адміністративній частині і також
редагувати змінювати ви можете додавати
по різним рулям ваших ваших коліжанок і
колег тому е знову ж таки ця опція є та
працює
а-а е
далі дивлюся інформацію і питання Більше
питань не бачу але як ми вже вам сказали
Якщо у вас виникають будь-які уточнення
труднощі не соромтеся писати нам на
технічну підтримку Support
echolnet.ua будь ласка єдине коли ви
пишете адресуєте запит обов'язково
формулюйте тему вашого листа гарно
опишіть в тлі листа ваше ключове
повідомлення аби наша служба підтримки
змогла вам якомога якісніше допомогти а
я гадаю що на
цьому на цьому власне з мого боку
презентація того як створювати курс в
декілька кроків завершена і гадаю що ми
можемо на останок передати нашим
організаторам цього заходу фінальним
словом Ну давайте не знаю алесандрі
Мабуть домо
Та добре добре дякую дуже дуже-дуже
Дякую компанії ракун я дякую всім за те
що створили Цей
курс звісно він засновувався на тому
курсі який наш тренінговий центр зробив
але те що ви створили те що ви зробили в
цій
онлайнверсії Це просто дуже чудово і
Олександра Дякую вам теж за те що ви
презентували Це Це набагато більше ніж Я
очікувала я настільки щаслива що ми всі
змогли змогли зібрати наші міски докупи
і нашу пасію наше бажання
створити такий чудовий ресурс для того
щоб надати підтримку
вчителям В їхній щоденній роботі щоб
допомогти
їм також щоб вони могли навчатися
відповідно до останніх
технологій Отже дякую Дуже дуже-дуже
дякую також всім за цю співпрацю яка в
нас була і я з нетерпінням чекаю щоб
почути ще більше щодо нових розробок в
рамках цього курсу та вчителів які
змогли на ньому
навчитися Дякуємо Олександро Ну і
завершальне слово мабуть звернуся
до своїх колег до світян яких сьогодні
було в піку там чи не 900 мені здається
людей одночасно дивилось нашу YouTube
трансляцію
от 867 точно я бачив чи було більше
просто не не щоразу слідкував от скільки
скільки лайків скільки
лайків Там он олексан Олександра євик Ну
хай хай скаже от Ану бистро долайкайте
хто не
лайкав от друзі Я надзвичайно Дякую вам
що ви долучилися що ви були такими
активними то точно так само як Олександр
сказав Якщо у вас будуть будуть
запитання
безпосередньо до курсу да технічні
звертайтесь в службу підтримки Якщо ж у
вас є пропозиції та з організаційної
точки зору е так само будь ласка
звертайтеся в директорат професійної
освіти пишіть нам ми будемо реагувати на
ваші прохання будемо вдосконалювати і
саму платформу і розвивати контент і
допомагати Чим можемо Ще раз дякую всім
і учас м вебінару і глядачам і
спікерам гарного вам завершення дня
завершення робочого тижня і тихих
спокійних вихідних до до нових зустрічей
до
побачення